this is a production of cornell
university
well thank you very much alan i'd also
like to say that i'm known as the
indiana jones of ancient fermented
beverages
and beer wine etc so
i think it's the topic it sort of
appeals to everybody and
you know over the course the last 20
years a lot of my research now has been
dedicated to this and
to really understand ancient fermented
beverages you also have to
test some modern ones so this is a nice
side
part to my job which takes me around the
world actually
and we do have uh and i'm going to be
discussing you know ancient wine
primarily in the middle east and as you
see here we've got a fresco from egypt
which uh
dates back to the new kingdom period but
actually we have examples of this going
back into the old kingdom period so from
about 2700 bc
down to the end of the egyptian
dynasties we have depictions like this
in the tombs and
the the purpose of this was to provide
lots of wine
uh for the deceased uh something that
is still a part of our sort of paradise
uh
idea in our western religions even islam
but you can see how detailed some of the
uh the evidence is from these egyptian
frescoes which we have nothing like it
really anywhere else in the ancient
world i mean you have to really come
down to the roman period before you
start to
you know pick up depictions of some of
the features of
wine making and these are can be you
know considered sort of stock
motifs that get repeated over and over
again so it doesn't include all the
details of the wine making but
i mean you can right away you can see
that they're training the vines
you know very carefully to keep the sun
exposure down
uh in the nile delta and you know we see
some of the uh
snapping out of the grapes where they're
holding grapevines
and usually singing a song to the snake
goddess
who's associated with grapes and wine
and then you see this red
must coming out at the bottom here which
you know suggests and
often you see that just a red you never
see a white coming out so this is
what's given people the idea that maybe
it's red wine principally that ancient
people would have drunk i happen to
disagree with that i think
it was very select
group maybe that had white wines because
you it's a
very small percentage of the grapes uh
have that albino mutation
and we do have evidence they'll be
coming to that suggests that white wine
is drunk as well
so then the juice was put into these
jars
and these are the famous canaanite jars
or amperas
and uh the fermentation is actually
carried out in those vessels and then
you had clay stoppers that were put on
and stamped with the name of the king
often later periods you have information
about
where the winery is located even the
name of the vintner
so you've got like the first wine labels
here that you're looking at it
and you can in some cases you can get a
very exact date
now they don't put a lot of information
about
the quality of the wine you know if you
want tasting notes
about all it goes as far as saying good
very good very very good and uh
that's about the extent of it but uh
you know how did i get involved in uh
studying ancient wine
and you know it was kind of a circuitous
route like you've already suggested you
know with
taking you know chemistry and uh you
know i minored in
english here at cornell and i am a
townie
uh so uh you know i have great uh
affection for this town actually
and um and i went to high school here
and it was during high school that
i sort of as i look back on it now is
where i sort of got my first
impetus maybe to pick up wine studies
because when i was 16 years old we went
off to germany
and for about two months traveling
uh bicycling around and uh we soon
discovered that beer was
less expensive than coca-cola so we
started drinking lots of beer
and the first night actually that we
were in germany
this is a long time ago we had dinner
with a
chemistry professor here who's a nobel
laureate
so that was a nice way to start out at
least getting some fermented
beverages on the beer side then 10 years
after that i came back
and to germany and i picked grapes on
the mosul
river and that was quite an experience
you know going along the very steep
slopes like you see here
it's a shaylee and
and i really discovered what a vintage
was at that time too because the first
night the vintner took us down
or he went into a small room and he
would go down in his cellar and come up
with one
wine after another and he would cover
the label and say okay what year
is that and at first you know i had no
clue
in the world you know what the year it
was and
but by the end of the night after we had
maybe 10
bottles of wine among five people and i
was totally
you know gone uh you know we could we
could really say you know 1959 was a
great year
69 was terrible and the year that we
picked there was 1971 which turned out
to be the
the vintage of the century in the mosul
well then i came back you know several
years ago and went to the
constantine frank winery and you know
look at the riesling grapes growing down
the steep slopes and i suppose you know
sort of a similar geology
to the shale and not quite as steep
maybe as the mosul
but it reminded me right away i mean
here we've got
you know a direct connection uh in in
terms of the great varietal
the geology and the type of grape and so
on it's uh
and the wines you know that are produced
in this region are quite comparable
and as alan has already mentioned i have
written a couple of books on this
subject
one was ancient wine and the most recent
one is
uncorking the past where what i
attempt to do um in this most recent
book
is not just talk about wine but
fermented beverages in general
and i try to bring together all the
various strands of evidence that we have
now archaeology i was trained as an
archaeologist
so you know i can assess that
information
i was also trained as a chemist and you
know took
like you say brain research
neurochemistry and so forth so
i'm interested in doing scientific
analyses
of residues uh that might tell us
something about the
uh the contents of the vessel and
and then we have ancient texts and art
i've already shown some artwork from
egypt you also see here
another funerary stila probably from
amarna
around 1350 bc the time of king tut
which is intriguing because this is on
the cover of the book
it's intriguing because we have a semite
as shown by the beard
uh drinking out of a an amphora
which usually would contain wine but in
this case using a drinking tube
which is more usually reserved for beer
because in beer drinking we have many
examples around the world of this
straws are generally the way that you
would drink it
you would do the fermentation in the jar
and then you've got lots of
gunk and so on coming up to the surface
and you just put your drinking tube
through all that gunk down to the
precious
liquid and
and then you have to have some
familiarity too with textual evidence
you know i i often have to turn to uh my
egyptian colleagues like
jim weinstein is here in the audience or
others who uh
you know maybe know the uh the egyptian
texts very well
or it could be uh acadian texts
that you know i took smatterings of all
these and so i know semitic languages
pretty well
and that helps in ferreting out some of
the
ancient evidence too again you have to
be very careful with
textual evidence because it it can be
misleading at times and a lot of times
you don't know the meanings of certain
words
then you have the modern situation
ethnography where
it may give you clues about what the
past was
and how beverages were made so you have
to assess that
evidence and finally experimental
archaeology which we've taken
quite a ways uh because when we've
discovered some of these ancient
beverages we've been able to recreate
them
uh i mean you take all these clues
together and try to get a composite
picture of what that beverage would have
been
and then you'd like to find out if it
really tastes any good
or you know how would you go about
making it
and so we've worked principally with a
brewery i'm not sure how familiar this
will be to
people here in the audience but called
dogfish dogfish had brewery
which is the fastest growing micro
brewery in fact in
the united states it's located in
delaware and
so we've done a whole series of
experiments
and some of these are available
commercially in fact if you come to the
tasting this afternoon
the reception at 4 30 you'll get to
taste the next beverage that i'll just
briefly
uh talk about um
as far as ethnography i'm also going to
be coming back
to the evidence for pottery
being used to make wine in georgia
and armenia principally i mean georgia
is the one that you know claims to have
this long tradition so i'll be
uh touching on that uh too uh so this is
the label
for our recreation of the beverage that
came from the
midas tumulus that was the actual name
of a
very large mound that's located at the
site of gordian
in central turkey and guardian was
capital the phrygians
and the dating according to
dendrochronology and radiocarbon dating
and so forth is about 740 to 700 which
fits with the textual evidence that we
have for the tomb belonging either
to midas who's a little bit later or his
father
uh gordius but it's definitely a royal
tomb it has the largest
iron age drinking set that's ever been
found and in the
drinking set were residue that came back
to the university of pennsylvania who
did the excavation
and they sat in a an archive
just two floors above my lab for
40 years and they were still in the
original paper bags the residues
and so this is like the easiest
excavation i was ever on i just had to
walk up two flights of stairs collect my
samples and come back down
but you'll see here it has this is the
golden thumb print
of midas the touch of gold but we put
in this recreation from dogfish muscat
grapes because we do have genetic
evidence of that being a very early
cultivar in the near east
then barley malt honey now we didn't
know what the bittering agent was it we
couldn't use hops because that comes
much much later
so i suggested well turkey is famous for
its saffron
and it has a very beautiful aroma and
taste so
why don't we go with that well this
turned out to be the most expensive
spice in the world too
so this is the most expensive uh mix
beverage or you can
call it a phrygian grog that sam
calgiani
the owner of dogfish had ever made it
it turned out very well that's all i can
say and if you come
at fourth it's won lots of gold medals
appropriately and
it uh it did show us that maybe ancient
people knew a little bit more about
beverages than we we thought
because when we first got this
combination of ingredients
wine beer and mead we said well
you know what in the world i mean would
you mix wine and beer together
well it turns out this is a fairly
common phenomenon all around the world
you take whatever fermentable sugars
you've got
and ferment it and also adding different
spices or
herbs becomes very important in terms of
ancient medicine
because many of the pharmacopoeias like
of egypt india
china and so forth going back quite
early a lot of times the way you get an
herb into solution is in an alcoholic
beverage
it could be wine or beer or something
else a mixed beverage
like this and you know you would try to
treat different diseases that way
uh now the first vessel that we worked
on came from about 3 500
bc that we were able to identify a
resonated
wine and i'll be coming back to some of
the chemical data for this
but this was out at our see i always
have to wear my tie
to be sure that you know i have this
continuity of tradition
uh the the red tie actually started to
flay
uh up here so now i've switched over to
the blue tie
this is a virginia battler uh who
was able to bring this a very large jar
from the calcalithic period and
we were able to sample it and analyze it
and as i say it turned out to be
a resonated wine inside this this jar
we'd already had success with ancient
organic materials like royal purple so
and i like i say go on and pick grapes
my associate
came from a a german wine
family and so we were both very
interested you know in doing uh studies
of ancient wine
and this was at the conference that we
had on ancient
uh the origins and ancient history of
wine back in 1991
that kind of propelled you know our
research after that
and we brought together you know people
from all different fields uh mainly
davis
uh uh people uh like
in viticulture and analogy uh vernon
singleton
harold omo but also dna specialists
archaeobotanists
historians people that had never really
been in the same room together
but were writing about wine and you know
we all interchanged ideas and it
this was uh powered by having maybe
three or four
wines at lunch every day and uh five or
six
in the evening so it was a a true
symposium you could say
uh and then we went back you know we
started thinking well you know can we go
back into an earlier period and get some
evidence for ancient wine
well the period that seemed most uh
important and possible for doing that
would be the neolithic period
when you have all the different uh
plants and animals being domesticated
people are settling down but you also
have the first pottery that's produced
say around 6000 bc
in the near east uh turns out in china
it goes back to 13 000 bc so we have
more prospects actually for china now
but i'm not going to talk about that um
but
the pottery is important because it
absorbs liquids
and that those liquids then get bound up
in the ionic structure of the clay
and so if you have a very good
preservation
you know if you're out in the desert of
egypt let's say or
underwater where there's not too much
oxygen in some cases
high up in the alps you might be able to
get an
organic sample that then you could
extract with different kinds of solvents
like
chloroform methanol is what we usually
use and uh
and do an analysis so this uh when i
came back to the university of
pennsylvania museum i just asked a
neolithic archaeologist
mary boyd if she knew of any samples
that might be uh prospectively good
that we could try analyzing and she said
well the site she'd excavated in iran
and the and the first vessel we analyzed
is also from iran
[ __ ] peruse which dates back to this
period
a couple thousand years earlier um had
some
yellowish residues on the inside of some
of the
shirts of fairly large jars
so here we see what one of the jars
looks like there were six of these lined
up in a kitchen
in just an ordinary house and they were
partly buried in the clay
floor and you had about 50 liters of
wine
all together in this uh in this house
and so they had when they first found
this back in 1968
they'd done some analyses uh to try to
determine what that yellow
residue was but the techniques or the
availability of chemists maybe
who had you know had you know
some very sophisticated instruments
wasn't available
so they really couldn't get very far
with it you know they thought
the yellowish color maybe suggested
yogurt or some milk product
but then we dug these out of storage
again
and should also point out that there
were clay stoppers that were
in the uh had fallen down close to these
vessels which are the same
width as the the mouth which is a very
important indication that
they're trying to seal up uh and also
this mouth
which is fairly tall for the period and
narrow
would be intended for a liquid so we had
samples that we were able to get out of
the university of pennsylvania storeroom
that looked like this and you can see
the yellowish
residue here this is only about three
inches
in height and uh and then we started
doing our analysis
so you know for the chemically
challenged
among you i don't know but we can talk
about this later this afternoon too i'm
not going to go into
all the details of this but uh we're
print we're looking mainly for tartaric
acid
because in the middle east this acid
is found in large quantity only in
grapes
so if we can identify tartaric acid then
we have a
a marker compound a biomarker
of a fingerprint compound that we can
then
use to argue that it is a grape product
now it could be grape juice it could be
wine
it could be vinegar you know if the
fermentation keeps going
along uh in the middle east where you
have fairly high temperatures though
if you have a liquid you know the juice
has been expressed from the grapes
and put into a vessel like the [ __ ]
fruits jar
it's going to have yeast on some of the
grapes that are going to start
fermenting with that
higher temperature in the first day or
so
so it's pretty hard to keep it from
keeping grape juice
you know unless you were to boil it down
and make some concentrate
so uh it goes to wine
and then the question is well does it
keep going to vinegar
and uh our argument there
is when you have a stopper like that
that's intended to act like clay
really because you especially if you put
it on its side
and we do have evidence some of the jars
were put on their side
the juice would get absorbed into the
raw clay and expand a little bit and
keep oxygen
from getting in and the other thing we
were able to detect
was a tree resin had been added to
this wine as well as the earlier one i
talked about
from godin tapi later in time
but these are generally pine resin or
terabith resin
that are added to prevent oxidation
and we know from later periods such as
the roman times that
one of the principal ways of preserving
wine was to add a tree resin
and they said humans spent more time
plenty of the elder
if you read his book natural history
he has a whole discussion of how to
preserve wine and he says that
humans have spent more time trying to
figure out how to preserve wine than
just about any other activity
it uh you know it's been a constant
theme i guess um so we use you know
techniques like
infrared spectrometry but uh our
preferred method right now for picking
up tertaric acid is
uh tandem liquid chromatography
uh using two mass spectrometer
uh so it would be a tandem lc mass spec
uh that we get you know fragments that
were able to
uh fairly you know we're able to
determine that tartaric acid is present
the um
i mean we're working with some other
techniques as well and then um
as far we usually typically do gas
chromatography mass spectrometry too
to identify any other additives
and you know together you can put
together a picture of what the
the residues uh composition would have
been
uh well okay so uh
we have wine you know found very early
in iran of all places you know going
back to 5400 bc the neolithic
but that gets you thinking well would we
ever have any evidence that goes back
even earlier and unfortunately when you
get back into the paleolithic period
the uh containers we don't have pottery
containers
so we don't have the sort of containers
that are going to preserve the ancient
organics that we're interested in
they probably would have used wine skins
or
howled out wood or maybe used a crevice
in the rock
but we can just you know assume by
say looking at africa uh today
even you've got a continent that has
numerous peoples you know speaking all
different languages and so on but
one commonality is they all seem to have
a fermented beverage
that's right at the center of their
culture so
you know from birth all the way to death
you know with celebrations and
what have you they will be making a
fermented beverage it could be
a millet or sorghum beer or palm
wine we take the the sap from a palm
tree
or it could be bananas that are
fermented
but it is a focus of
almost all cultures that you find in
africa and why is that significant well
if we came from africa originally
you know and we came out of africa you
know a hundred thousand years ago
um you know this suggests that uh we
probably were already
pretty focused in on certain fermented
beverages i mean
and you can make a biological argument
in this regard too they'll be coming to
so here we've got our primitive ancestor
who is very visually oriented as we all
are and you know he would spot you know
some high sugar fruit
and uh you know this maybe looks like
kumquats or
whatever but let's say you're you're
moving out of africa up
the eastern mediterranean uh the first
place where you would see the wild
beta spinifera is maybe lebanon
because of the wild binifer does not
grow
south into egypt so
uh so you know the person
you know is coming up they're interested
in uh these fruits
and you know they start to pluck them
put them into their primitive container
and they leave them for there for a few
days and the
weight of the fruit above will be
pressing down on the fruit below and you
get juice coming out
and uh you can assume that then
fermentation is probably occurring in
these very primitive containers
and so the human you know
primate you know comes down and you know
tastes the liquid you know smells it and
uh
maybe drinks a fair amount of it and
gets uh you know a whole new sensory
experience along with a mind-altering
experience that
i think they would remember and they
would come come back to it
and so the only problem though is that
their primitive container they couldn't
preserve the beverage
so you might call this a stone age
beaujolais nouveau
or i put sour ale in here too because
we do have enzymes in our saliva that
can break down carbohydrates into
sugar it's fermentable so that you you
can also be exploiting all different
kinds of
chewing of grains stalks
you know any sort of a high carbohydrate
source by chewing spitting it out
and waiting for an insect to bring some
yeast by to get the fermentation going
but since they couldn't preserve it
uh you had to drink it quite fast
and so you know we get into the whole
discussion you know
of how alcohol really is part of
life on this planet i mean if maybe the
earliest uh
energy system was a fermentation system
and maybe the the first biotechnology
of humans was fermented
fermenting uh beverages so you know all
the way from the fruit fly on up to the
elephant
you know they all are attracted to sugar
and alcohol
uh and it goes beyond that i mean we
we've got
you know enzymes in our livers that
break down alcohol into energy
and an alcoholic beverage is actually
safer than drinking water
because the alcohol kills microorganisms
so people that drank a fermented
beverage probably live longer
reproduce more so it has that going for
it
and then you know as these gentlemen
here gathered around their
watering hole in some primitive times
show it also brings people together so
it provides a social lubrication where
people
you know start to break down their
inhibitions and open up to each other
it um you know has the
uh the medical effect that i already
mentioned where you can put different
herbs into solution
uh and if you were only living 25 years
you know you would be on the lookout for
any herbs in your environment
that you could dissolve into an
alcoholic beverage and perhaps
get some relief you know from pain
or you know maybe even lower your
cholesterol i don't think they thought
about that too much
and but i think the really important
aspect of fermentation is the mind
altering effect
and you know they couldn't see the yeast
this is a magnified
view of the yeast budding saccharomyces
cerevisiae
but they could observe its effects so
here you've got the carbon dioxide
roiling off the surface
of the liquid that's fermenting
and you're also getting alcohol produced
at the same time
so they would see that and they would
say you know there's some sort of a
outside force it seems at work here and
if you did the fermentation
in a vessel like the [ __ ] fruits jar
and you have all this carbon dioxide
evolving and starting to shake things
around you might actually see the jar
itself start to move
and you know and that would be uh
kind of amazing to these people and so
you can then begin to understand why
fermented beverages become the center of
religions
you know so even in our western
religions i mean wine is important to
judaism and christianity
but like the african cultures i
mentioned too um
so it uh you know it just is working on
so many different levels biologically
socially
medically and uh religiously i think uh
this is why
you know despite what uh you know the
after effects of prohibition you know of
all the negatives
that you hear there is this positive
side that i think has to be brought out
of course mondavi tried to put it on his
label that
you know wine was the the
really the mark of civilization and uh
the alcohol tobacco firearm people said
nope you can't put any positives there
you know it's
it's strictly forbidden um
so you know we've got uh the you know
this sort of backdrop
of the in the paleolithic period that we
can surmise that fermented beverages are
important
but we don't have the actual chemical
evidence for that yet but then
uh the neolithic is when we first get
the pottery and i've mentioned the [ __ ]
farooz
jar but there's other evidence that
we're still working on that
in different parts of the mountainous
near east
like georgia up in the caucasus
where we do have evidence of either
artistically some uh suggestive chemical
evidence which we're still working on
uh of sherds like this
and what's interesting about these
shirts is that
they do have motifs on them might
suggest grape clusters
and maybe this is a person the stick
figure you know that's arms up in the
air kind of dancing around at some
festival
and if we go back even earlier before
pottery we have
chlorite vessels that are made out of
chlorite
that are very absorbent and again we've
gotten lots of ancient organics from
these but we still
are not convinced what the beverages are
or whether it's wine
but you know again they have these sort
of celebratory
scenes and in this case the man and
woman are dancing with a turtle
but unfortunately these shirts from
georgia
usually went through a very uh intense
hydrochloric acid bath
and so that we get out very small
amounts of residue
and it's quite problematic you know you
get a lot of your
ancient organic material which isn't
huge to begin with
the midas residue i talked about uh
before i mean we had literally pounds of
residue
but here you might be down at the
milligram level and you know it starts
to get a little
iffy at that point in georgia too we
also have
evidence of grape seeds quite early
and the way that these are usually
distinguished at least on a
visual botanical level is that the the
domesticated grape seed is a little bit
shorter and broader and then the
um the wild uh grape
vitus finifera
oh well the other way around so the wild
is shorter and broader and the
domesticated which is going to be the
hermaphrodite grape
is generally longer and narrower
and we do have wild grapes you know at
sites you know throughout the
mountainous area
of the near east so it uh they generally
you know fit into this wild type
the problem if you have enough samples
of grape seeds to work with you know you
can make a
some sort of statistical argument but
the the two distributions
actually overlap quite a bit so it's
sometimes uh a problem and in some cases
uh
cult grape cultivars like pinot noir
actually have the form of the wild grape
pip
so you know you just have to be a little
cautious about this and
this is where dna ultimately is going to
be really important
now this was the viticulturalist who had
been working on grapes from one of these
neolithic
sites uh ravaz ramishvili
and we're in tbilisi where they had a
whole
set of cultivars from georgia that grew
at the experimental station
there and he
said well we have this very early site
in georgia called chulaveri
and the grape pips are all the
domesticated long
narrow type and we're talking about only
five or six
pips and i said well you know wouldn't
it be nice to do some dna work on these
uh and uh he said well you know
he had sort of went out of the room and
had to think about it came back he said
no he didn't really
think that was you know because we'd
have to destroy the grape seed
and uh i said well you know it'd be for
the cause of science you know we find
out whether we have a domesticated or a
wild grape perhaps
and he left the room again and he came
back and he
he agreed okay he's going to give me one
pip
so i i have this one pip still in my lab
waiting to be analyzed once the dna
techniques have been worked out
especially the extraction of ancient dna
from grapes is difficult but
but in true georgian fashion because
georgia culture
is totally centered around wine i don't
know if anybody
here has been to georgia but you know
every meal you've got a person that's
picked out is the toastmaster who
does all the the toasts and the toasts
you know just go on and on and on
so he brought out a nice mascot
alexandruli
to celebrate you know the handing over
of this one
great pip which is still in my
storage room at the university of
pennsylvania museum
but now why would you what is the
domestication of the grape i mean
what's what's important about it uh well
it's because it's a hermaphrodite
which has the male and female on the uh
the same
uh flower and um
so you you don't have to worry about
insects you know transferring the pollen
i mean
or wind um and you get uh
you know much more predictability as far
as fruitfulness and you see a lot more
fruit
and i guess in some cases people say
that the clusters of the grapes are
larger too
so you know this is a these are it's a
pretty small set of organs here
you know the pistil and the stamens and
so forth you
need a sort of magnifying glass to you
know see if you've got the hermaphrodite
or just the the female wild plant or the
male wild plant uh so how did humans
ever determine this because vedic
finifera is the only grape species in
the world that was ever domesticated
we have maybe 20 25 species here in
north america
you know the same number in china but uh
so far there's no evidence that any of
those were ever domesticated it was just
vetosphinifera
and so you know maybe it's a little more
difficult to figure out you know when
you've got a hermaphrodite or not
and um it um
and you have the further problem okay
maybe once you select out the
hermaphrodite by seeing the large size
and
a lot of fruit is how do you perpetuate
that
the seeds are too variable so they're
not going to give
another hermaphrodite and you would have
to know some horticultural techniques
i mean that's sort of the assumption
that is built into this so you know how
to transplant
grapevines or run it under the ground
layering to have the grapevine come up
in another place
and you know multiply it that way
but it really does assume a lot of
understanding
of of you know what is going on
not not you know scientifically
obviously but that they have a
very fruitful plant and then can select
out and perpetuate it in some way
and then for also other traits so here
we've got
the mayor's nipple grape from central
asia which is quite interesting
i i did write in here sapphirabi which
is one of the
georgian grapes i guess it's grown up in
the ukraine too
it turns out this one is not so close to
some of the earliest dna evidence that
we have from
looking at modern
cultivars and and wild plants
but it um it is one of the georgian
varietals
um so the thought then
is is that in the neolithic period we
could have had domestication of the
grape occurring we've got domestication
of lots of other
plants and animals
and that would you know help to explain
why we have the quantity of wine
that we see at a small site like [ __ ]
farooz
and
[ __ ] farooz is in the zone of the wild
vine so this purplish area here
shows where the wild vine grows today
and presumably in antiquity
you see it doesn't extend down toward
egypt here
so when they came
well you know we don't know the actual
ancient distribution but let's say
uh you know the lebanon uh you know is
where the furthest uh south
it would would have come and um
and so up in this this general area is
where we have the possibility for the
domestication of the grape
and here's that other side i mentioned
with the the grape seed cholavari
over in georgia
now we don't know at [ __ ] peru's whether
they were using
domesticated or wild grapes there's no
way to know that yet
unless you were able to do some dna
analysis
and but it is in the the zone so it's a
possibility
and i showed some evidence from georgia
of
uh you know very early pottery that
maybe is related to grapes and wine
this is another possibility and then
eastern turkey is
is turning out to be really important i
think for
the early neolithic period as a possible
area too
so for instance when they're putting in
some of the dams along the euphrates
rivers
they came on to neolithic sites that go
back to
8500 bc 9000 bc
which are much earlier than uh other
sites in other parts of the mountainous
uh near
east and they even have
uh you know really spectacular uh
architecture um you know in this case
uh some kind of a oryx uh
bowl and then a there's a fox here
probably
and some sort of crane maybe here but
these are all
inside buildings that they think could
be
some sort of religious shrine i mean
in archaeology of course when you don't
understand what something is you assume
it's got to be religiously oriented
uh here's the back of a male head with a
kind of a
strange serpent wiggling its way up
so uh you know this area looks
interesting now
they haven't reported from these sites
any vessels that we could actually
analyze
but we're in uh an area there that there
is evidence for
domestication of eincorn wheat uh
genetically
and uh and the excavators of these sites
um
are suggesting that the reason the
people were settling down
or are building these religious shrines
you know a sort of long-term basis
is that they were exploiting the eincorn
wheat
to make beer and this is one of the
the arguments you can make all around
the world really is that you know people
settle down for
uh reasons of agriculture you know to be
close to their crops to be able to take
care of them and so forth and in the
process
they're starting to build small villages
and you get specialization as the
process continues so
they don't have any actual vessels
though that prove that eincorn
wheat was used to make a fermented
beverage but eastern turkey does have
other
evidence for early founding
founder crops like
there's a bitter batch for instance
and so you know it's an area where we
could have had the domestication of the
grape
as well uh now this is the sort of
question you know we've we've been
pursuing is
was there a single domestication of the
grape in one place
and then was it then spread to other
parts of the world
by transplantation and winemaking
techniques going along with it
or did you have multiple uh areas where
it was domesticated
you know maybe like the spaniards for
instance are very interested
in having a separate domestication uh
all the way
in the western uh area of distribution
of the wild grape
and you can refer to this as the the
noaa hypothesis because
after all noah was the first winemaker
when he got off
the ark on mount ararat the first thing
he did was plant a vineyard
and make some wine because there were
some
bad consequences that came out of that
too but
this would be the idea that we do have a
single place and time
when the grape was domesticated and then
it spread out from there and indeed
there are vineyards still growing on the
sides of mount ararat close to ancient
sites uh
this is sort of like the eve hypothesis
you know the notion that we have a
single
african mother um but you know it's a
it's a hypothesis that we would want to
to look at pretty closely and one of the
reasons we think
that it may work is because we have a
wine
culture as suggested by the pottery
vessels that we've analyzed
the grape seeds and so forth at
neolithic sites
throughout this mountainous region and
that wine culture and by wine culture i
mean
something that really dominates
everybody's existence like when i was
growing up in uh in the finger lake
region we didn't have much
good wine you know we might have a sweet
concord you know every so often
uh and but look in the last uh 30 years
i mean it's just taken off and it just
shows you
you know in the new world and you can
multiply you know finger lakes over and
over again you know
to california oregon washington
australia south africa and so forth
once wine or any fermented beverage
really for that matter takes hold
it really can consume people and you
know become a center
of of um social relations
and and what have you so it's uh uh you
know fine dining and all the rest of it
so
if we had a evidence then for a wine
culture of that sort developing in this
mountainous region of the near east
where we have the greatest genetic
variability of vitus vinifera
so this is often thought as the world
center
of the grape of the eurasian grape
and then that in later periods is
spreading down to egypt
first to the jordan valley which is
around 4000 bc we have evidence there
and then on to egypt around 3000 bc on
the same thing's happening on the other
side of the fertile crescent uh going
down
to shiraz by 3000 bc
it would seem as if we've got a
domestication event occurring up here
that then is spreading out
and then ultimately spreads out to the
whole world
and we've you know pursued this to some
extent by
trying to collect wild grape samples
over in eastern turkey
now i haven't uh i've been asked by
people in iran
to come over there and do some sampling
which we should do but
so far i've not done that eastern turkey
was maybe
exciting enough we had to we went to the
upper part of the tigris river which you
see right here
in eastern turkey and you know we just
then scoured
areas that there was no domesticated
grape
anywhere near the these sites but they
were sometimes very difficult to get to
so here's my colleague from the
university of ankara on this very steep
slope in this case
i'm actually holding a plant that is a
hermaphrodite
wild plant so it's one that the ancient
humans would have had to select for
to ultimately perpetuate and it's in
between
a a male wild vine and a female wild
vine
so this is like the perfect situation
for uh
you know selecting and unfortunately
though
this is an early spring and this is like
a raging torrent
even though it looks a little uh placid
at the moment
and right after this picture was taken
and i stepped back
i almost fell into the river
and it was only the sure uh
feet and shoes of my colleague here that
sort of pulled me out and i
i basically then had to you know clamor
up the side of the the river to get to
the top
uh and in the process i you know i tore
my pants and stuff but you know at least
i'm alive here to tell you the stories
so where did our dna studied letas well
these are the the groups that we used
you know european cultivars and wild
vines
and you can have questions about what's
really wild i won't get into that too
much
and then we had georgia representative
armenian turkey
and some of our own samples and then
we don't have iran very well represented
unfortunately
but the the study that was published
showed that using 20 micro satellites
that
uh uh that it was the near east
that uh it was where the domestication
would have occurred
and in fact there's a person here used
to be here at cornell
sean miles who i believe some people
here in the audience
know or have worked with that did a
single nucleotide
polymorphism study 9000 of them
that also points to the mountainous near
east is where the domestication would
have occurred
and what's kind of interesting here is
that these wild
european grapes don't overlap at all
with the cultivated european
grapes and are much closer to the wild
turkey
and in some cases for georgia
we see that the pinot the pinot group is
very
closely related to some of the georgian
varieties now i won't try to say their
names
because it's in our paper uh
you know georgian is pretty tough
language actually and
uh it um
but other other once you have pinot
transplanted to europe it then seems to
spread out into the
syrah group and it really is kind of a
key
uh grape uh cultivar uh that develops
and
and then some of these middle eastern uh
varieties too are
are closely related to nebiolo and
chassa laws and so forth so
it really is pointing to uh a single
domestication
uh noaa hypothesis being substantiated
in the near east
and um and then it's going to be
transplanted like i say down
into to egypt
but i just wanted to say a few words
about another site in egypt
now i don't know if you can all see this
it's probably blocked out some but
there's a site of a by-dose here
which is
we have a tomb from one of the earliest
pharaohs
actually ruler dynasty zero
who's been called scorpion the first
that the german
group archaeological institute in cairo
excavated
and the dating of the the wine jars that
we've analyzed from this site
go back to 3150
bc and this is what some of the jars
look like now this is before the nile
delta was planted
with grapevines it's around 3000 bc that
we get the
royal wine making industry of egypt
developing
so 150 years or so before that
they have these jars that come and are
deposited
in a tomb of this pharaoh in
abidos out in the desert see a very good
preservation and there were three rooms
that were filled with these jars
which is not an egyptian type you could
say right away
and there were about 700 of these jars
that had been brought
and they couldn't have wine that was
made in egypt because there was no
royal winemaking that had been
established yet
so where did they come from and you know
what what can we say about them
uh well we did neutron activation of the
clay of the
the pottery here and it pointed to
the wine originating from the jordan
valley
or each the hill country to either side
of the jordan valley
and that's about 700 kilometers away
from abidos so
you have to imagine them filling up 700
jars putting them on donkeys to get it
over land
maybe on a boat if that such existed
bringing it up the nile depositing it in
this tomb
now these other rooms were filled with
beer vessels clothing
the king was actually laid out here with
a scepter
and uh recently we did some chemical
nails re
uh analysis we knew already that it was
a resonated wine
but we thought we'd use uh some
techniques like
solid phase micro extraction to tell us
more about the volatiles that might have
been bound up in the wine
and it turned out that we had very good
representation
of you know most probably of
herbs that also are found only in the
eastern mediterranean like time
savory and
these these sorts of herbs
again i think they fit into this ancient
medicine picture
and so what we've done is gone ahead and
started analyzing some of the
compounds in the
ancient wine for its anti-cancer effects
we've been working with the university
of pennsylvania medical and
abramson cancer center and what we call
this is archaeological oncology digging
for drug discovery
and one of our chinese beverages has a
compound
i won't get into it today but which
knocks out all kinds of cancers
the abidos jars were also interesting
because they had
some of the earliest long strands
of dna from saccharomyces cerevisiae
some of these are about 800 840
base pairs in length which is quite
unusual for such an early sample am i
running out of time
okay well let me just feed through here
i'll skip
the spread of the grapevine over to
italy as
interesting as that is it it's a
fascinating story of how probably the
phoenicians are the main
carriers of the grapevine and
one of our projects that we're doing now
is in southern france to try to
figure out when the etruscan wine
amphoras came in
and that sort of jump started the french
wine making industry as
late as uh 400 b.c i mean the french
didn't really
to my my opinion did not have any wine
even
though we think of you know the french
as being sort of the epitome of wine
making
uh it comes much later and it's brought
from other places this is the site that
we're working on in southern
france with its etruscan amphora spread
out
and then i was going to say a few words
about quaveries you know pottery
uh you could call it jug wines um
and these are huge jars that they still
make in in georgia and
and then are uh exporting those out to
countries like slovenia italy and we're
going to
try i guess this afternoon some amphera
wines
uh and this is a whole technique that we
used to think it only went back to the
iron age this is an early
site that was excavated in armenia
kamar blue but you know
the tradition of burying the whole jar
underground i mean it makes sense maybe
in terms of temperature
control and so forth but these jars are
totally above ground i mean the amphora
making here is not underground and
but the georgian theory that they have a
very early
underground jar winemaking tradition
got some substantiation from this uh
cave in armenia
dated to about 3000 bc that had
underground jars like this where you
could have run the jews right into them
and it was in a burial setting so
the wine might have been used even for
uh
for you know offerings to the dead uh so
here's a here's a quebri
and that that quevery is just a georgian
term for an underground pottery jar
with all the materials rising to the
surface
this is an italian uh interpretation of
how they would they handle the wine
so they would be you know punching down
the cap and then
you're getting leaves here and this wine
is going to sit
in that jar with all the skin
seeds and what have you for nine months
until it's
reopened and you take off the stone here
but the advantage i think of the the
pottery
is that it does exchange ions or it can
hold different compounds in place so
that you can have
catalysis oxidation reduction uh what
have you polymerization
but it depends a lot on the clay
composition in the near east we have
terra rasa which is very high iron but
in other places you might have something
else
but i just like to contrast that with
oak because i mean we think of oak is
you know
mellowing out everything but it really
introduces
a whole series doesn't have the zeolite
properties the absorption properties
but it does introduce all these
caramelization products vanillin
lactones and so forth and so if you want
a really pure
varietal expression of terroir you might
better go with pottery
but that can be discussed so here i
think in a way
this whole story of the grape and the
wine it illustrates what
biomolecular archaeology is capable of
and you know how much more we're going
to really
find out in the future here we've got a
situation where one species gets
domesticated
and now is responsible for 99.9 of the
wines in the world it's quite an amazing
story and this uh
whole story i think of civilization and
wine
is is in a lot of ways you know the
history of civilization is a history of
wine or fermented beverages
in which the grapevine is you know
intertwining itself and wine is being
introduced into all these cultures you
know whether it's
provence in southern france or
even sunny ithaca okay well let's stop
at that point
thank you
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu
you